now let us go on and look at
mountains the Quran has more than a
dozen verses stating that God placed
firm and unmovable mountains on the
earth and in some of these verses the
mountains are listed as either a
blessing for believers or a warning for
the
unbelievers one example of this is found
in the Sor lman 311011 where the
mountains are one of five
warnings it says he was cre he has
created the
heavens says he has created the heavens
without supports that you can
see and has cast Ela onto the Earth firm
mountains rasia lest it should shake
with
you in the prophets
elenia 21:31 as one of seven warnings we
read and we have set on the earth firm
mountains lest it should shake with you
with them finally in the
16:15 says and we he has cast Ela unto
the Earth firm mountains rasia L it
should shake with
you we see then that the Believers and
unbelievers are told that Allah has done
this great thing he's thrown down and
plac the mountains so that the Earth
will not Shake violently with them
therefore we must ask ourselves what did
they understand in the next two verses
another picture is
given the new
anaba
7867 have we not made the Earth an
expanse and the mountains of stakes
elala Oten as those used to Anchor a
tent in the
ground and then the overwhelming El gash
1719 do they the unbelievers not look at
the mountains elel how they've been
pitched like a
tent here men are told that the
mountains are placed as tent pegs tent
pegs keep the tent stable so again the
idea is put forward that the pegs the
mountains will keep the Earth from
shaking a third picture is presented in
the word rasia used for mountains this
word comes from the Arabic root arsa and
the same root is used for the Arabic
word for anchor to throw out or cast The
Anchor is
Ela so instead of cast The Anchor to
keep the ship from moving we have cast
the mountains to keep the Earth from
shaking from these pictures it is clear
that Muhammad's followers understood
that the mountains were thrown down like
tent pegs to keep a tent in place like
an anchor to hold a ship in place to
stop the Earth from moving I.E limit
earthquakes but in fact this is false
the forming of mountains causes
earthquakes therefore these verses
present a definite problem Dr moris
bukai recognized this and discussed them
in his book The Bible the Coran science
after quoting the above verses about
mountains he says modern geologists
describe the folds in the earth as
giving Foundation to the mountains and
the stability of the Earth's crust
results from this phenomenon of these
folds when asked about this professor of
geology Dr David a young says while it
is true that many mountain ranges are
composed of folded Rock and the folds
may be of large scale it's not true that
the folds render the crust stable the
very existence of the folds is evidence
of instability in the crust in other
words mountains don't keep the Earth
from shaking their formation caused and
still causes the surface of the Earth to
shake geological theories at the present
time propose that the hardened crust of
the earth is made of sections or plates
which slowly move in relation to each
other sometimes the plates separate like
North and South America SE separating
from Europe and Asia and Europe and
South Africa and sometimes they go
together and they slide next to each
other and they bump into each other and
then they cause
earthquakes an exampl as time of
mountain formation is found in the
Middle East where the migration of
Arabia toward Iran has resulted in the
zyro range in in
Iran in many parts of the world as one
travels along the roads one sees a
hillside where where the Sandstone
layers which were horizontal when they
were deposited are now sticking up at
Angles and so here you can see these
Sandstone layers which were horizontal
in the beginning now they're sticking up
at
75° where they they were pushed up there
by an earthquake by the mountains being
formed sometimes the plates get caught
on each other and stop sliding during
this period great forces are built up
when the forces of friction are overcome
the piece of plate that was stuck
lurches forward causing the shock wave
of a Thrust quake and all of a sudden it
Go th like this in a recent earthquake
it was calculated that the Coco plate in
Mexico suddenly jump forward 3
m well if your house suddenly jumped 3
MERS it would be a
catastrophe another type of m a mountain
is that formed by volcanoes lava and Ash
from inside the Earth are are thrown out
and piled up until a high mountain is
formed even From the Bottom of the
Sea and we can see this kind of action
in this picture I hope you can see
it not clear is
it the ocean
crust is right here
and the continental crust is there and
the oceanic crust is going down under
the continental crust and mountains have
been formed here here's a
volcano and here is the magma or the
molted rock going up through the volcano
and here's another volcano with Magma
going up and so this is how the
mountains are formed and earthquakes are
formed
in the case of some ous mountains molten
rock intrudes into the throat of a
volcano's opening and cools form a
relatively dense intrusion which extends
below the surface of the Earth so this
if this got stuck and sealed then it
would be like a
plug however it's not a root it does not
bear the weight of the mountain it's
really a plug therefore on occasion
pressure builds up under the plug and
the volcano explodes as happened in the
South Pacific at Kato in 1883 when the
whole island was blown away and it
happened in Mount s Helen in our days
when the mountain was blown away we can
conclude from this information that
mountains were formed originally with
movement and shaking and that now in the
present earthquakes are caused by their
continued formation when the plates
Buckle over each other there are
earthquakes when the volcanoes erupt
there can be
earthquakes however it is clear that the
followers of Muhammad were understanding
these verses to say that Allah threw the
mountains
[Music]
down as a tent pegs or anchors to keep
the Earth from shaking throwing the
mountains down into the Earth may be
poetry but to say that mountains keep
the Earth from shaking is a severe
difficulty which is out of step with
modern
science now we're going to take a little
look at what the sun says about about
the Quran says about the
son in the Sur of the CF
1886 it says until when zul corain
that's Alexander the Great reached the
setting of the sun he found it set in a
spring of murky water I'm sorry in 20th
Cent science 20th century science the
sun does not set in a spring of murky
water and then in the Criterion aluron
2545 to 46 it says hast thou not turned
thy Vision to thy Lord how he prolongs
the shadow if he will he could make it
stationary then do we God make the sun
its
guide what about this as the sun's if
you think of the sun overhead you have
no Shadow or a little tiny Shadow and
then as the sun goes down your shadow
gets longer on the other
side well the sun is stationary in
relation to the Earth it's not what
causes the shadow to shift the rotating
Earth guides the
Shadows so if you demand 20th century
accuracy the Sora should say the
rotating Earth causes the Shadows to
change I we look at a different subject
Solomon's death whether this is science
I don't know maybe
sociology Solomon's Dead He's propped up
on his staff says the Gins work for him
as Solomon desired then when we decreed
death upon Solomon nothing showed them
his death except the little creeping
creature of the earth which noded away
his staff and when he fell the Gins came
clearly saw clearly how if they had
known the Unseen they would not have
continued in the humiliating penalty of
work so here's Solomon he's dead he's
propped up on his staff like a wakf in
Morocco overseeing only a road gang and
no cook comes to ask him for what he
wants for dinner and no General comes
for orders and none of his no Nobles
come to say let's go hunting no one
notices I'm sorry I do not believe this
story and it won't F fit 20th century
sociology or 7th Century sociology where
the king would never be left alone like
that now finally let us look at
milk it says in the Surah of the be and
1666 we pour out to you from what is
within their cattle in their abdomen the
cattle's abdomen between excretions and
blood milk pure and agreeable to the
drinkers the abdomen where the
intestines are sorry in 20th century
Medical Science the abdomen where
intestines are is where the intestines
are the mammory glands are under the
skin in humans they're under the skin
here in cattle they're under the skin
between the
legs no connection there's no connection
between the breasts and the intestines
and their feces in any way feces though
in the body it really is outside of the
animal and animals finished with it it's
not connected to milk or to anything
else and finally going to look at
communities the S of the cattle El Lam
638 there is not an animal on the earth
nor a being that flies on two wings but
forms communities like
you speaks about no animal on Earth not
a being that flies and then it says that
every one of them is communities like
you and I assume that the Quran is
speaking about we
humans well some FL in some
spiders when they finish mating the
mother eats the father well I'm glad
that my wife didn't eat
me even in bees the extra male
drones are thrown out to die well I'm
glad also that after I we had four
children then my wife didn't push me out
of the house
too finally the
Lions when a lion gets old a male lion
gets old a young lion comes along and
drives him away from his own wives and
the Young Lion takes over the
wives but what he does with the Cubs the
Cubs of The Old Lion he kills them
all so I do not think that this sentence
is true all of the communities are and
all of the animals do not live in
communities Like
Us in conclusion it is clear that the
Quan has many scientific errors as a
generality the Quran mirrors and
reflects the science of its time the
science of the 7th Century ad we came
here to seek truth I've done my best to
present valid
information if you want to see all the
references my book the Quran and the
Bible in the light of History and
Science is for sale outside that door at
a bargain price
tonight May the God of all truth guide
you thank
[Applause]
you thank you Dr
Campbell for your presentation now we
have brother sabil
Ahmed presenting an introduction of our
next speaker Dr Zakir
n asalam
alikum it is my pleasure to introduce
one of the best schar of our time Dr
Zakir Abdul Karim
nyak a 34 years
old he is the president of Islamic
Research Foundation Bombay
India though a medical doctor with
professional training Dr Zak n is known
as a dynamic International orator on
Islam and comparative
religion Dr Zakir n clarifies Islamic
viewpoints and clears misconceptions
about Islam based upon the Quran Hadith
and other religious scriptures as well
as adhering to reason logic and
scientific
facts he is popular for his critical
analysis and convincing answers to
challenging question questions posed by
audiences after his public
talks he appears regularly on many
International TV and satellite TV
channels programs in several countries
of the world he has authored books on
Islam and comparative
religion he has also participated in
several
symposiums and dialogues with prominent
personalities of other religious faiths
ladies and
gentlemen may I call upon Dr Zakir n to
present his
[Applause]
talk alhamdulillah
[Music]
respected Dr William
Campbell Dr marakas Dr Jamal
badwi brother Samuel Nan Dr Muhammad n
my elders and my dear brothers and
sisters I welcome all of you with the
Islamic
greetings may peace mercy and blessings
of Allah subhana wa ta'ala be on all of
you the
topic of today's dialogue is the Quran
and the Bible in the light of
science the Glorious
Quran is the last and final
Revelation which was revealed to the
last and final messenger Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him for any book
to claim that it is a revelation from
almighty God it should stand the test of
time previously in the olden days it was
the age of Miracles
alhamdulillah the Quran is the Miracle
of
Miracles later on came the age of
literature and
poetry and Muslims and non-muslims alike
they claim the Glorious Quran to be the
best Arabic literature available on the
face of the Earth but today is the age
of Science and Technology let us
analyze whether the Quran is compatible
or in compatible with modern
science Albert Einstein said science
without religion is lame and religion
without science is blind let me remind
you that the Glorious Quran is not a
book of signs s c i e n c e it's a book
of signs s i g NS it's a book of
ayats and there are more than 6,000
signs ayats in the Glorious Quran out of
which more than a thousand speak about
science as far as my talk regarding
Quran and science is concerned I will
only be speaking about scientific facts
which have been established I will not
be speaking about scientific hypothesis
and theories which are based on
assumption without any proof because we
all know many of times science takes
u-turns
Dr William Campbell who wrote a reply to
the book of Dr Maris
Bale the Quran the Bible in the light of
History and Science he says in his book
that there are two types of approaches
one is a concordis
approach which means a person tries to
bring a compatibility
between the scripture and Science and
the other is the conflict approach in
which a person tries to bring a conflict
between scripture and science like how
Dr William Campbell has done very well
but as far as the Quran is concerned
irrespective whether a person uses a
conflicting approach or a concorded
approach as long as you're logical and
after a logical explanation is given to
you not a single person will be able to
prove a single verse of the Quran in
conflict with established moral
science Dr William
Campbell has pointed out various alleged
scientific errors in the
Quran and I'm supposed to actually
refute in the re but since he chose to
speak first I will be refuting a few
points in my talk I will reply to the
major part of his talk mainly dealing
with embryology and with geology the
remaining inshallah inshallah I will try
a level best to reply in the
rebuttal I have to do both I can't do
Injustice the topic the topic is Quran
and Bible in the light of science I
can't only speak about one scripture Dr
William Campbell hardly spoke about one
or two points about the Bible which I
shall deal with inshallah I will speak
about both inshallah I want to do
justice to the
topic as far as Quran and modern science
is concerned in the field of
astronomy the scientists the astronomers
a few decades
earlier they described How the Universe
came into
existence they called it the big bang
and they said initially there was one
primary nebula which later on it
separated with a big
bang which gave rise to galaxies Stars
Sun and the Earth we live in this
information is given in a nutshell in
the Glorious Quran in Surah Amia chapter
21 verse number 30 which
says do not the unbeliever
see that the Heaven and the Earth were
joined together and we clothe them aund
imagine this information which they came
to know recently the Quran mentions 1400
years ago when I was in school I had
learned that the sun in respect to the
Earth it was stationary the Earth and
the moon they rotated about the axis but
the sun was
stationary but when I read a verse of
the Quran saying in 21 verse number 33
it
says it is Allah who has created the
night and the
day the Sun and the
Moon each one traveling in orbit with
its own
motion now alhamdulillah modern science
has confirmed the quranic statement the
Arabic word used in the Quran is Y bahun
which describes the motion of a moving
body when it refers to a Celestial body
it means it is rotating about its own
axis so Quran says the Sun and the Moon
they revolve as well as rotate about
their own axis today we have come to
know that the sun takes approximately 25
days to complete one
notation it was edin Hab who discovered
that the universe is expanding the Quran
says in Surat chapter 51 verse number 47
that we have created the expanding
Universe the vastness of space the
Arabic word mosa refers to vastness the
expanding
Universe regarding the topics on
astronomy which Dr William Campbell
touched I will deal in the rebuttle
inshallah in the field of water cycle Dr
William gamble pointed out certain
things the Quran describes the water
cycle in great detail I know William
Campbell mentioned four stages in his
book he mentions four A and B the last
one he didn't mention in the slide I
don't know why it says that reping the
water table he missed out here maybe
because not mentioned in the
bible he said there is not a single
verse in the Quran which speaks about
evaporation Quran says in chapter number
86 verse number 11
that by the capacity of the Heavens to
return and almost all the comment of the
Quran they said that this verse of 86
verse number 11 refers to the capacity
of the heaven to return back rain
meaning
evaporation Dr William Campbell who
knows Arabic may say why didn't Allah
subhana tala specifically
mention meaning the capacity of the
heaven to return back rain why did Allah
mention specifically
now we have come to know why didn't
Allah do that in his Divine wisdom
because today we have come to know that
besides those osphere theer above the
earth besides returning back rain it
even returns back other beneficial
matter and energy of the earth which is
required by the human beings it does not
only return back grain today we have
come to know it even returns back waves
of telecommunication of Television of
Radio by which we can see TV we can
communicate we can hear the radio and
besides that it even returns back the
harmful Ray of the outer space back on
the other side and
absorbs for example the ultraviolet race
of the sunlight is absorbed by the
ionosphere if this was not done life on
the Earth would have ceased to exist so
Allah subhana wa tala is far
superior and far more accurate when it
fath by the capacity of the heaven to
return and the remaining things as you
mention is there in the Quran you can
refer to my video because I said the
Quran described the water cycle in great
detail regarding what he said about the
Bible he so stage one and stage three in
the first slide and the second stage one
three and then two that the rainwater is
taken up he says and then the water come
on the earth this is the philosophy of
phase of MST in 7th Century BC he
thought that the spray of the ocean was
picked up by the wind and fell into the
interior as rain there's no Cloud
mention there
in the second quotation Dr William
Campbell gave first is according to him
evaporation which we agree we don't mind
having the Concord approach with the
Bible then rain falls down and then are
the clouds formed that is not the
Complete Water
Cycle alhamdulillah the Quran describes
the water cycle in great detail in
several places how does the water rise
evaporates form into clouds the clouds
join together they stack up there
thunder and lightning water comes down
the clouds mov into the interior they
fall down as rain and the replenishing
of the water table and alhamdulillah in
great detail the Quran speaks about the
water cycle in great detail in several
places in Surah n chapter number 24 vers
number 43 in Sur room chter number 30:48
in surum 39: 21 in 23 ver number 18 in
Sur room CH number 30 vers number 24 in
Surah alh 15 verse number 22 in Surah CH
number 7 verse number 57 in Surah chter
number 13 verse number 17 in Surah fan
25 verse number 48 and
49 in Surah f chapter number 35 verse
number n in y 36 verse number 34 in
Surah jha 45 verse number 5 inah number
50 verse number 9 in ch number 56 verse
number 68 and 17 in several places Surah
M CH 67 vers number 30 the Glorious
Quran speaks about the water cycle in
great
detail Dr William cble spend maximum
time on embryology about half his talk
quite a lot on geology and touched on
other six topics I've noted
down in the field of geology we have
come to today the geology that tell us
that the radius of the Earth is
approximately
3,750 Mi and the deeper
layers they are hot and fluid and cannot
sustain
life and The Superficial part of the
earth crutch which we live on it is very
thin hardly 1 to 30 miles some portions
are thicker but majority 1 to 30 mil and
there are high possibility that this
superficial layer the Earth's crust it
will shake it is due to the folding
phenomena which gives rise to mountain
ranges which gives stability to this
earth Quran says in Surah chapter number
78 verse number 6 and 7 we have made the
Earth as an
expanse and the mountains as
Stakes the Quran doesn't say mountains
were thrown up as Stakes mountains as
Stakes Arabic word aad means Stakes
meaning tent Peg and today we have come
to know in the study of modern geology
that mountain has got Deep Roots
this was known in the second half of the
19th
century and the superficial part that we
see of the mountain is a very small
percentage the deeper part is within
exactly like a steak how it is driven in
the ground you can only see a small part
on Top the majority is down in the
ground all like a tip of the iceberg you
can see the tip on the top and about 90%
is beneath
water the Quran
says in surash 88 verse number 19 and
chapter number 79 verse number
32 and we have made the mountain
standing firm on the earth made the
mountain standing firm on the
Earth today after modern geology has
advanced and Dr William Campbell said
that by the theory of PL
tectonics it was propounded in
1960 which gives rise to mountain ranges
the geologist today do say
that the mountains give stability to the
Earth not all geologists but many do say
I have not come across a single
geological book and I challenge Dr
William gamble to produce a single
geological book not his personal
correspondence with the geologist that
doesn't G VI his personal correspondence
with Dr Kitmore documented proof and if
you read the book the Earth which is
referred by almost all the universities
in the field of geology one of authors
by the name of Dr Frank press who was
the adviser to the former president of
USA Jimmy Carter and was the president
of the Academy of Sciences of USA he
writes in his book that the mountains of
West shap it has Deep Roots within and
he says that the function of the
mountain is to stabilize the earth and
the Quran says in Surah Amia chapter
number 21 verse number 31 in Surah
lukman 31 verse number 10 as well as in
Sur n chapter number 16 verse number 15
that we have made the mountain standing
firm on the earth lest it would
shake with them and with
you the function of the mountain in the
Quran is given to prevent the Earth from
shaking nowhere does the Quran say that
the mountain prevents the
earthquake and Dr William Campbell said
he writes in his book and even the talk
that you find in the mountainous regions
there are various earthquake and
mountains cause earthquake
point to be noted nowhere does the Quran
say that mountain prevents earthquake
the Arabic word for earthquake as
William C knows Arabic is z or
zah but the words used in these three
verses I quoted it is tamid Tam means to
shake to sway to swing and Quran says in
Surah lman 31 verse number 10 as well
asah chapter number 16:1 15 we have put
on the earth Mountain standing firm lest
it would shake with you it
shake with you indicating if the
mountain were not there if you would
have walked if you would have moved even
the Earth would have moved with
you if you would have swayed even the
Earth would have SED with you and we
know normally when we walk on the earth
the earth doesn't shake and the reason
for this is according to Dr Frank press
and Dr majar Who from Saudi Arabia and
he wrote a full book on geological
Concept in the Quran answering almost
everything what Dr William Campbell has
said in
detail and Dr William Campbell in his
book he writes that if mountains prevent
the shaking of the earth then how come
you find earthquake in the mountainous
regions I said nowhere does the Quran
say Mountain prevents earthquake
earthquake isal and if you see the
definition in the Oxford dis it says
earthquake is due to convulsion of The
Superficial crust of the earth due to
release of compressed sismic waves due
to crack back in the rock or due to
volcanic
reaction Quran speaks about zala in Z CH
99 but yet speaks about tamik to prevent
the Earth from shaking with you and in
reply to the statement that if mountains
prevent earthquakes how come you find
earthquakes in mountainous region the
reply is that if I say that medical
doctors they prevent the sickness and
disease in a human being and if someone
argues
if doctors prevent the sickness and
diseases in a human being how come you
find more sick people in the hospital
where there are doctors than at home
where there are no
[Applause]
doctors in the field of oology the
Glorious Quran says in Surah fan chapter
25 verse number 53 that it is Allah who
has let free two bodies of flowing water
one sweet and palatable they are the
salt and bitter though they meet they do
not mix between them there is a barrier
which is forbidden to be test passed
Quran says in 55 vers number 19 and
20 it is Allah who has let free two
bodies of flowing water though they meet
they do not mix between them there is a
barrier which is forbidden to be
trespassed previously the commentator of
the Quran wondered what does the Quran
mean we know about sweet and salt water
but between them there is a barri barer
though they meat do not mix today after
advancement of oceanology we have come
to know that whenever one type of water
flows into the other type of water it
loses its constituents and gets
homogenized into the water it flows
there is a slanting homogenizing area
which the Quran refers to as bar unseen
barrier and this has been agreed upon by
several scientists even of America by
the name of Dr hey you
oologist and Dr William Campbell writes
in his book that it is an observable
phenomena the fisherman of that time
knew there were two types of water salt
and sweet so Prophet Muhammad during the
expedition to Syria he may have gone in
the sea or he might have spoken to these
fishermen sweet and salt water is an
observable phenomenon I agree but people
did not know that there was an unseen
barrier until recently the scientific
point to be noted here is the Barak not
the sweet and the salt
water in the field of
embryology Dr William Campell spend
approximately half of his talk on that
time will not per to reply to every
small things which are illogical I'll
just give a brief reply which will be
satisfactory inshallah and for more
details you can refer to my video casset
Quran modern science and my other
cassets on Quran and medical
science there were a group of Arabs who
collected the data dealing in the Quran
about embryology and the Hadith dealing
with embryology and they presented it to
Professor
kitu who was the chairman and the head
of the Department of anatomy in the
University of Toronto in
Canada and at present he's one of the
leading scientist in the field of
emology after reading the various
translations of the Quran he was asked
to comment and he said most of the
verses of the Quran and the Hadith are
in perfect confirmity with modern
emology but there are a few verses which
I cannot say that they are right neither
can I say that they are wrong because I
myself don't know about it and two such
verses were the first vers of the Quran
to be revealed
fromter 96 verse number 1 and2 which
says read recite or Proclaim in the name
of thy Lord who created who created the
human beings from something which clings
a Le like
substance regarding Dr William Campbell
statement that to analyze the meaning of
a word you have to
see what was the meaning at that time
when it was revealed at that time when
the book was
written and he rightly said that to
analyze the meaning you have to analyze
the meaning at the time it was revealed
and to the people who it was meant for
as far as this statement of his is
concerned regarding the Bible I do agree
with it totally because the Bible was
only meant for the children of Israel
for that time it's mentioned in the
gospel of Matthew chapter number 10
verse number five and six Jesus Christ
peace be upon Him tells his disciples go
ye not in the way of the Gentiles who
are the Gentiles the non-jews the Hindus
the Muslims but rather go to the lost
sheep of the House of Israel J CH peace
be upon him said in the gospel of
Matthew chapter number 15 verse number
24 I am not sent but to the lost sheep
of the House of Israel so Jesus Christ
and the Bible were only meant for the
children of Israel since it was meant
for them to analyze the Bible you have
to use the meaning of the word which was
utilized at that time but the Quran was
not meant only for the Arabs of that
time Quran is not meant only for the
Muslims the Quran is meant for the whole
of
humanity and it is meant to be for
eternity Quran says in Surah ibraim
14:52 in Surah Bak chter number 2 verse
185 and Surah zumar 39:41 that the Quran
is meant for the whole of humankind and
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him was
not sent only for the Muslim of the
Arabs Allah says in the Quran inia
chapter number 21 verse number
107 that we have sent thee as a mercy as
a guidance to the whole of
humankind so as far as the Quran is
concerned you cannot limit the meaning
only for that time because it is meant
for
eternity so one of the meanings of alak
is leash like substance or something
which clings so professor kmore said I
do not know whether the early stage of
embryo looks like a leech and he went in
his
laboratory and he analyzed the early
stage of an embryo under a microscope
and compared it with the photograph of
Lee and he was astonished at the
Striking resemblance
this is the photograph of a leech and
human
embryo what Dr William Campbell showed
you is the other perspective of
it if I show this book it looks like a
rectangle if I show you like
that it's a different
perspective that diagram is given in the
book the diagram you show on the SL live
in there and I'll deal with it
inshallah profor Kei Moore after about
80 questions asked to him he said if
you'd have asked me these 80 questions
30 years
ago I would not be able to answer more
than 50% because embryology has
developed recently in the past 30 years
he said this in the '
80s now do we believe in Dr Ki Mo whose
statement is available outside in the
fire if video C is available
this is the truth recorded statement so
will you believe Dr William Camp's
personal conversation with Professor Kei
Moore or the one mentioned in this
book with Islamic Edition as well as the
photograph that I've shown to
you and in the video C available outside
you can see it he makes those statements
so you have to choose which is more
logical personal discussion with Dr
William gamble or his statement on video
like how Dr William Campbell showed my
video 100% proof what I said moon is
reflected light I'll come to it later
on and whatever additional information
you got from Quran and Hadith it was
incorporated
later into this book the developing
human the Third Edition and this book
got an award for the best medical book
written by a single author in that year
this is the Islamic Edition that was put
forward by shik Abdul Ma zani and
certified by Keith Moore
himself the Quran
says in Sur CH 23 verse number 13 and
Surah Haj CH 22 verse number five and no
less than 11 different places in the
Quran that the human beings have been
made from an A Min quantity of
liquid like a trickle that's remaining
in the K in Arabic a very small quantity
today we have come to know in one Su
mission in which there are several
millions of sperm only one is required
to fertilize the ovam the Quran refers
as
nut Quran says inah s 32 vers number 8
we have created the human beings from
solala that means the best part of a
whole the one sperm which
fertilizes the O out of the millions of
sperm the Quran refers to AA best part
of the whole
and Quran says in Surah insan 76 verse
number two we have created the human
beings
from a minute quantity of mingle fluid
referring to the sperm as well as the
ovam both are required for the
fertilization the Quran describes the
various embryological stages in great
detail of which the slides was shown to
you about William Campbell he helped me
to complete this topic
it's mentioned Sur 23 ver number 12-
14 the translation is that we have
created the human beings from A Min
quantity of liquid then placed it in a
place of
security then we made it into an alak a
leech like
substance something which clings a c
clot of blood then we made that alaka
into a mud a chew like
lamb then we made the muda
into bones then clothed the bones with L
flesh then we made it a new creature
Blessed Be Allah who's the best to
create these three verses of the Quran
speak about the various mological stages
in great detail first the placed in a
place of
security has got three
meanings one is something which clings
and we know that in the initial stages
nembo
clings to the utan wall and continues
clinging till the
end point number
two that it also
means a leech like substance and as I
discussed earlier the embryo in the
initial stages does look like a leech
besides looking like a leech it also
behaves like a leech it receives its
blood supply from the mother like a
blood sucker and the third meaning which
Dr William Campbell objected to that
that is the right meaning the K CL of
blood and that's why Quran has a
scientific error and I do agree with him
that Dr William Campbell didn't agree he
said how can it mean a k CL of blood
because this is the case in the Quran is
wrong I'm sorry to say Quran is not
wrong Dr William Campbell with due
respect to him he's wrong because today
today after advancement of
embryology even Dr Keith Moore
he says that in the initial stages the
embryo beside looking like a leech also
looks like a conil clot of blood because
in the initial stages of the stage of
alaka 3 to four weeks the blood is
clotted within closed vessels and Dr
William Campbell made it easy for me he
showed you a
slide it will be difficult for you to
see but this is the slide he showed you
this is
exactly what prophet kitm said looks
like a clot in which the blood is
clotted within closed vessels and during
the third week of the embryo the blood
circulation doesn't take place it starts
later on therefore it assumes the
appearance of a clot and even if You
observe the concept test that's after
abortion takes place you can see it
looks like a clot only one line answer
is sufficient to answer all the
allegation of Dr William Campbell is
that the stages of the Quran while it
describes the embryological stages is
only based on appearance
appearance first is the appearance of
alaka a leash like substance as well as
a clot of blood and Dr William Campell
lightly said that some ladies come and
ask please remove the
clot it does look like a clot and the
stages are based on an
appearance it is Created from something
which appears like a clot which appears
like a leech and is also something which
clings then the Quran says he made that
alaka into a mud a like L Prophet Kei
Moore took plaster seal and bit between
his teeth to make it look like a muda
the teeth mark resemble the
somites William Campbell said when the
alaka becomes a
muda the clinging is yet
there it is there late and half months
so the Quran is wrong I told you in the
beginning the Quran is describing the
appearance the leech like appearance and
the clot like appearance is changed to
The Chew like appearance it yet
continues to cling till the end there's
no problem but the stages are divided on
appearance not on the
function later on Quran says we made the
mud into isama bones then clothed the
bones with
flesh the William Campell said and I do
agree with with him that the precursors
of the muscles and the cartilages that
is the bones they form together I agree
with that today emology tells us that
the primordia of the muscles and the
bones they form together between the
25th and the 40th Day which the Quran
refers to at the stage of muda but they
are not developed they are not developed
later on at the end of the seventh week
the embryo takes
form of human appearance then the bones
are formed today modern embryology says
the bones are formed after the 42nd
day and it gives an appearance of a
skeletal thing even at this stage when
the bones are formed the muscles aren't
formed later on after the seventh week
and the starting of eighth week are the
muscles formed so Quran is perfect in
describing first alaka then mud then
isan then clothe it with flesh and when
they form
the description is perfect and professor
kmore said that the stages that how it
is described in modern emology stage 1 2
3 4 5 it's so confusing the quranic
stage on embriology describing on the
based of appearance and the shape is far
more
Superior alhamdulillah therefore he
said therefore he said that I have no
objection in accepting that Prophet
Muhammad is the messenger of God and
that this glorious Quran has to be a
divine revelation from almighty
God it's mentioned in chapter number 4
vers
56 it speaks about pain previously the
doctors they thought that the brain was
only responsible for feeling of pain
today we have come to know besides the
brain there are certain receptors in the
skin which are responsible for feeling
of the pain which we call as pain
receptors Quran says in Surah n 4:56
that as to those who reject our signs we
shall pass them into the Hellfire and as
often as their Skins are roasted we
shall give them fresh skin so that they
shall feel the pain indicating there is
something in the skin which is
responsible for feeling of pain which
the Quran refers to as pain
receptors
Prophet who is the head of the
Department of anatomy in changma
University in Thailand only on the basis
of this one verse he proclaimed the
shahada in the eighth medical conference
in Riyad and said
muham that there's no God but Allah and
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon Him is
the messenger of
Allah I started my
talk by quoting the verse of the
Glorious Quran from Sur f chapter 41: 53
which
says that soon we shall show them our
signs in the furthest SE of the horizons
and into their soul until it is clear to
them that this is the
truth this one verse was
sufficient to prove to Dr Tashan that
Quran is a divine revelation some may
require 10 signs some may require 100
some even after a thousand signs are
given they will not accept the truth
Quran calls such people as in Bak 2 vers
number
18 the death the the dumb the blind they
will not return the true part the Bible
says the same thing in Gospel of Matthew
chapter number 13 verse number 13 seeing
they see not hearing they hear not
neither will they
understand regarding the other parts of
embryology I will deal in my rebuttal
inshallah if time
permits I have to do justice to the
other part Also regarding Bible and the
right of science at the outside let me
tell you that Quran says in Surah
13:38 that we have given several
Revelations by name only four are
mentioned the Torah the zabur the injil
and the Quran the tah is theah the
Revelation which was given to Moses
peace be upon him the zabur is theah
which was given to David peace be upon
him the injil is the the Revelation
which was given to Jesus peace be upon
him and Quran is the last and final
Revelation which was given to the last
and final messenger Prophet Muhammad
peace be upon
him let me make it very clear to
everyone
that this
Bible which the Christians believe to be
the word of God is not the inil which we
Muslims believe was revealed to Prophet
Jesus peace be upon him this Bible
according to us it may contain the words
of God but it also contains words of
prophets words of historians it contains
absurdities obscenity as well as
innumerable scientific
errors if there are scientific points
mentioned in the
bible there are possibilities why not it
may be part of the word of God in the
Bible but what about the scientific
errors what about the unscientific
portion can you attribute this to
God I want to make it very clear to my
Christian brothers and
sisters the purpose of my presentation
on Bible in science is not to hurt any
Christian's
feeling if I presenting if I hurt your
feelings I do apologize in advance the
purpose is only to point out that a
God's revelation cannot contain
scientific
errors as Jesus Christ peace be upon you
said search the truth and the truth
shall free you you have the Old
Testament you have the New Testament now
you should follow the last and final
testament which is the Glorious Quran
as far as Dr William Campbell is
concerned I can be more liberal with him
because he has written a book Quran
Bible in the light of History and
Science he has given a presentation and
he's a medical doctor I don't have to be
very formal with him as far as the other
Christian brothers and sisters are
concerned I apologize if I hurt your
feelings during the presentation let's
analyze what do the Bible say about
modern
science first we deal with astronomy
the Bible speaks about the creation of
the
universe in the beginning first book
book of Genesis first chapter it's
mentioned it says almighty God
created the heavens and the Earth in six
days and talks about a evening and a
morning referring to a 24-hour day today
scientists tell us that the Universe
cannot be created in a 24hour period per
of 6 days Quran 2 speaks about
sixs Arabic word singular is pluralist
aam it can either mean a day of 24 hours
or it is a very long period and Y an OK
scientists say we have no objection in
agreeing that the Universe it could have
been created in six very long period
Point number two Bible says in Genesis
chapter number one verse 3 and five
light was created on first day Genesis
1: 14- 19 the cause of light stars and
the sun Etc was created on fourth day
how can the cause of light be created on
the fourth day later than the light
which came into existence on the first
day it's
unscientific further the Bible says
Genesis chapter 1 verse 9-13 Earth was
created on the third day how can you
have a night and day without the Earth
the day depends upon the rotation of the
earth without the earth created how can
you have a night and
day point number
four Genesis chapter number 1 verse 9-13
says Earth was created on Third Day
Genesis 1 verse 14- 19 says the sun and
the moon was created on the fourth day
today science tells us that Earth is
part of the parent body the sun it
cannot come into existence before the
sun it's
unscientific Point number five the Bible
says in Genesis chapter number one verse
number 11-13 the vegetation the herbs
the shrubs the trees they were created
on the third day and the sun Genesis
chapter number one verse 14 to 19 was
created on the fourth day how can the
vegetation come into existence without
sunlight and how can they survive
without
sunlight Point number
six that the Bible says in Genesis 1
verse number 16 that God created
two lights the greater light the sun to
Rule the Day and the Lesser light the
moon to rule the night the actual
translation you go to the Hebrew text it
is
lamps lamps having light of its own and
that you'll come to know better if you
read both the verses Genesis 1 verse 16
as well as 17 verse number 17 says and
almighty God placed them in the
firmament to give light to the Earth to
give light to the Earth indicating that
Sun and the Moon has its own light which
is in contradiction with established
scientific knowledge that we have